Tucked away in the shadows of Bly Manor are
tons of creepy hidden details, secret ghosts
and Haunting of Hill House easter eggs you
didn't notice on your first viewing.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the spookiest things
you missed in The Haunting of Bly Manor.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
One of the most rewarding parts of rewatching
The Haunting anthology series
is discovering all the clues laid out in the
early episodes to the big twists and reveals
at the end of each season.
When Dani arrives in London, she stops to
look at a map right in front of a huge clock
or chronograph display.
There are cogs and stopwatches nestled within
the larger timepiece, hinting towards the
importance of time and the various time loops
within the story that's about to be told.
And it also foreshadows the countdown or ticking
clock that hangs over Dani
after she lets Viola possess her in the finale
and the eternal fate that awaits her as the
Lady of the Lake.
Another detail foreshadowing the final destination
of many of Bly Manor's characters is in the
small painting in Dani's room at the hostel.
There are three famous world landmarks in
the picture;
the Eiffel Tower, Big Ben, and the Statue
of Liberty.
Big Ben is, of course, in London, where Dani's
haunted journey begins,
and the Statue of Liberty points to how in
the finale Dani and Jamie leave England and
go travelling in America where they settle
down together.
As for the Eiffel Tower, that's a pointer
to Dani and Jamie visiting Owen in Paris where
he opens up the restaurant he's always dreamed
about.
And Dani's room number at the hostel 2-1-7
pays homage to Stephen King's The Shining.
The number is the same as the haunted room
in the novel, and fittingly Dani continues
to be haunted by the ghost of her ex-fiancé
in that room.
Of course, Haunting creator Mike Flanagan
also wrote and directed Doctor Sleep, the
sequel to Stanley Kubrick's movie of The Shining.
Another Shining reference pops up later in
the children's classroom at Bly Manor.
Look very closely at Miss Jessel's desk where
there are a handful of Scrabble tiles that
spell out the word "REDRUM".
"REDRUM" is the creepy message that appeared
in both The Shining and Doctor Sleep, and
which spells "MURDER" backwards.
This easter egg foreshadows how Peter Quint
will later kill Rebecca when he takes possession
of her body and drowns her in the lake.
A particularly spooky Hill House easter egg
in Flora's room is the smiley face on top
of a chest of drawers.
This is a nod to Mr Smiley who turns out to
be the abusive foster father of one of Theo's
clients, as well as a terrifying apparition
that appeared to Theo one night.
What's especially interesting about this is
that the smiley face is positioned above Flora's
Lady of the Lake doll which lies beneath the
cabinet.
In Hill House, the little girl explained to
Theo that Mr Smiley lived below the house.
Similar to Mr Smiley, the Lady of the Lake
is a malevolent monster who emerges from below
the surface and it's why Flora insists that
Dani leave the ghostly doll where it is.
"Put her back.
She stays...
there."
Another night, just after Dani tucks Flora
into bed, she accidentally knocks into the
Lady of the Lake doll which has made a sudden
appearance in the middle of the floor.
This little incident foreshadows how Dani
will stumble into Viola's path at the end
of the eighth episode.
And when Dani then invites Viola into her
body, watch the scene very closely because
you can see how the colour of one of Dani's
eyes changes from blue to brown.
Prior to this, both Dani's eyes were blue;
but from this point on, she has one blue and
one brown eye, a mark of the beast now living
in her body.
The same thing happens to Miles in the seventh
episode when he lets Peter take over.
"It's you.
It's me."
"It's us."
Miles collapses, but when he wakes up, you
can see how this eye has gone from blue to
brown.
And it also happens to Rebecca when Peter
takes possession of her.
Because Rebecca has brown eyes to begin with,
in her case the eye changes to blue.
The drawing with the words "Come Home" that
Flora sends to Miles at boarding school, calling
him back to Bly Manor,
is a sly call-back to Hill House and how Olivia
Crain both in life and death told her children
to "come home"/to do just that.
"when I flash the porch light twice..."
"Time to come home."
"Come home, my love."
"Come Home Nell" was also a message that Theo
uncovered underneath the wallpaper at Hill
House.
There's a deep cut reference to Hill House
when Peter gives Miles his dad's old lighter
and says
"Just don't burn the house down, please."
This is a nod to how Luke, actor Oliver Jackson
Cohen's character in Hill House, tried to
burn the place down with a lighter.
And you can spot an easter egg to the Bowler
Hat Ghost which haunted Luke in Hill House
in the scene where Dani is waiting to be picked
up by Owen.
Right next to her, is a hat shop which seems
with a number of bowler hats on display.
An early clue that Peter Quint had been possessing
Miles comes when the young boy presents Dani
with a bouquet of roses in the second episode.
In the next episode, during a flashback scene,
we see Peter give Flora the same white and
red flowers in Rebecca's presence.
And the way that Jamie freaks out when she
finds that Miles has taken the flowers
"They weren't ready to be cut!"
is a subtle allusion to how Peter took Rebecca's
life too soon.
And perhaps also to how he killed Mrs Grose
when he was in control of Miles.
As Peter Quint continues to develop his relationship
with Miles, he explains:
"People are like locked rooms.
They've all got different locks, and you've
got to guess the shape of their key."
And the different methods, or unique keys
as Peter puts it, that he uses to manipulate
those around him such as Rebecca or Henry
is reminiscent of how Hill House's Red Room
changes its appearance and function to appeal
to different members of the Crain family,
and lure them into its trap.
"You found the key."
"You want to know the secret?
We are the key."
"But it was always the Red Room.
It put on different faces so that we'd be
still and quiet while it digested."
Building on this theme of keys in Bly Manor,
you can spot a key-shaped key holder by the
door in Peter's time loop scenes.
There are no keys on it though, perhaps a
comment on how Peter can't escape from this
time loop that he hates so much.
Likewise, after she dies Viola finds herself
locked away in a never-ending loop until Perdita
finds the key to the trunk that Viola had
set aside for her daughter.
And it's no coincidence that Jamie is wearing
a chain around her neck with a padlock attached
on the day that Dani brings her the rings
they'll wear as a symbol of their love for
each other.
The Haunting of Bly Manor also plays around
with the idea from Hill House that the manor
is alive and we can see this in the way the
Narrator describes it when Dani arrives.
"..and it yawned open to welcome her home."
"The rooms were larger at night, as though
the house itself had inhaled deeply."
And there's another nod to that when Dani
sees Flora's dollhouse open up all by itself.
The dollhouse is a replica of Bly Manor and
appears to have some kind of enchantment
as the dolls inside move around depending
on where the characters and the ghosts they
represent are in the house.
Dani lives the rest of her days with differently-coloured
eyes,
and another detail that represents how she's
not entirely human any longer is the doll
that Flora gives her when they say goodbye.
"Are you sure you wanna give me this one?"
"You must have it.
It's you."
Flora regarding Dani as a doll means deep
down the little girl understands something
has changed in the au pair,
because it contrasts sharply with what she
said to Dani when she first arrived at Bly
Manor.
"Is that me?"
"Why, no, silly.
You're you.
It's just a dolly."
When Peter reveals his plan for him and Rebecca
to permanently take possession of Miles and
Flora, he explains how the children will be
together with their parents forever.
"you're gonna be tucked away.
In the forever house, just like we said."
"With Mum and Dad?"
The idea of a "Forever House" is a throwback
to Olivia Crain's dream home.
"This is our forever house."
Although after she died, that effectively
became Hill House itself.
"This is our forever house.
It always was.
Nothing bad will ever touch them ever again."
In the sixth episode, there's a flashback
scene where Dominic Wingrave confronts his
wife Charlotte about her affair with his brother
Henry,
and we see a note on the fridge with the word
"hello" written repeatedly.
This is a clever bit of foreshadowing of the
reveal later in the episode that it's Henry
who's been responsible for the silent calls
at the manor,
because this is exactly what Dani says when
she picks up the phone.
"Hello?
Hello?
Hello?"
There's a cunning clue to Henry's illicit
relationship with Charlotte in some of the
early episodes via an advert for a production
of Hamlet on a London double-decker bus.
Both the Haunting of Bly Manor and the famous
Shakespeare play feature men who have relationships
with their brothers' wives and children who
lose their fathers.
Also, in both the play and Bly Manor, the
dead father's son finds himself tormented
by a ghost.
The Haunting of Bly Manor is the latest in
a very long line of adaptations of Henry James's
19th-century novella The Turn of the Screw.
And creator Mike Flanagan has said that the
1961 film version of the story, The Innocents,
was a huge influence on his show,
with Dani's surname Clayton being a tribute
to that movie's director, Jack Clayton.
Another notable homage to the film is the
prayer-like pose of Mrs Grose's hands in her
opening credits portrait which tips its hat
to the opening credits of The Innocents,
where the children's new governess played
by Deborah Kerr clasps her hands in prayer.
Another seminal moment from The Innocents
which Bly Manor draws on heavily is the song
'O Willow Waly', which pops up repeatedly
throughout each adaptation.
Both Bly Manor's first episode and the film
begin with the song and several seconds of
complete darkness,
with the melancholy lyrics neatly alluding
to the final scene of Bly Manor.
But now alone I lie...
...till my lover return to me.
Where the elder Jamie waits to be finally
reunited with Dani.
"O Willow Waly" is often used to indicate
when Flora and Miles are being possessed by
Rebecca Jessel or Peter Quint.
The first instance of this is when young Flora
is singing it when Dani arrives at the manor.
♪ Till my lover returns to me♪
"Oh, what a beautiful song!"
"What song?"
Flora responds that way, because it was Miss
Jessel who was in control and singing the
song in that moment.
Miles whistles the song after acting inappropriately
around Dani.
And the music box plays the tune when Miles
grabs Dani around the neck and begins to strangle
her.
"Got you!"
"Jesus, Miles!
Ease up!"
The tune indicates that Peter Quint is in
control of Miles at each of these moments.
In the Netflix show, it's shown that Viola
is the origin of the mournful song as we see
her sing it when she performs her nightly
walks to her daughter's bedroom.
Flanagan's series also draws on several key
moments of animal imagery in the original
film.
For example, the dove Miles kills at school
recalls the one whose neck he broke at home
and kept under his pillow in the movie.
Then there's the many pictures of butterflies
on Flora's walls and the butterfly hairclip
that Miles gives Dani that belonged to Miss
Jessel,
which recall the stark image of a butterfly
being eaten in The Innocents.
And there's the painting of a turtle on the
classroom wall, which is a call-back to Flora's
turtle in The Innocents and,
given the Stephen King easter eggs elsewhere
in this scene, possibly also an allusion to
the cosmic turtle from King's Macroverse.
And, of course, the TV series also pays homage
to the Turn of the Screw novella by Henry
James through its use of a prologue
with a mysterious storyteller who name-checks
the book's title in their dialogue, as also
happens in the original story.
"And if a child gives the effect, another
turn of the screw...
...what do you say to two?"
In a deviation from the novella though, Flanagan's
series returns to this storyteller in an epilogue
which reveals her true identity.
The ships on the wallpaper in Miles's room
and in model form are a reference to the repeated
ship imagery and maritime metaphors in the
novel,
such as the opening chapter where the children's
governess compares Bly to a "great drifting
ship" lost at sea.
Miles, Flora, and Uncle Henry's family name,
Wingrave, is a reference to the name of the
family from another of Henry James's short
stories, "The Romance of Certain Old Clothes",
which the eighth episode of Bly Manor draws
upon heavily for its tale of two sisters,
their husband, daughter, and a locked trunk
filled with dresses and jewels.
And Viola and Perdita's surname Willoughby
was the name that Henry James gave his characters
in the first version of that story
before he revised it to Wingrave when it was
republished several years later.
Fans of the brilliant iZombie will remember
actor Rahul Kohli who plays cook Owen as medical
examiner Ravi Chakrabarti
and there's a nice nod to his post-mortem-performing
role in that show in the final episode of
Bly Manor when the narrator explains what
Owen did after Hannah Grose died.
"some in the village said that the cook rode
with her all the way to the coroner.
And there, he insisted on cleaning her himself."
And Owen's love of puns, including the name
of his restaurant, A Batter Place,
"I mean, I've made some good cakes in my day,
but this one is batter."
echoes iZombie's endlessly pun-loving ways
from its episode titles to its comic-book
segues to its character names.
There are, of course, a stack of hidden ghosts
lurking in the background of Bly Manor, and
to discover over 80 of them tap here to watch
my full video
revealing all the ones I found including the
Soldier, the Vicar, the Plague Doctor, the
Doll Face Ghost, plus the secret hostel ghost!
There's also a link in the video description.
So, did you spot any other interesting details
or Hill House easter eggs in Bly Manor?
Leave your comments below!
And if you enjoyed this video, a thumbs-up
is hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my full Bly Manor playlist with
a breakdown of the ending and what that final
shot with Jamie really means or tap right
for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!